[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'suis l'assassin je suis restée bouche
bée un peu trash essais et pêche mais
aussi la ratp
je suis assez libre jeunesse bénichou
pdg j'ai ma vigne
je suis triste je suis à moteur
[Musique]
j'suis cgt
michel weill p
et de là une heure
en juillet font qu est [ __ ] free
toujours bien fait et michou
[Musique]
free du 19 mai capte plus vivace
je suis d box je viens ce pays je suis
aidé juillet mais péter je suis sur
scène je suis à refaire je suis le
soudan herbert et bosh qui met à nu
jetable à brouillard et j'ai débarqué
lundi mais rhodia j'ai monté ma carte
grise une dent et mon patron
nous assurant
une nouvelle qui tance dedans
certificat
domicile et à sidi mes vaccins et mon
groupe sanguin meetic est métropolitain
[Musique]
jeunesse
je suis un peu si je vais mais je suis
un fan chevet des blessés s'effectue
aussi l'aï rappelé
[Musique]
pdg emmanuel jeu suite au report suite à
votre
je suis est ce un jeu
comme ce
je suis cgt
me sers des mots clés dubai
de là une heure suisse
focus et pdf est toujours élevé et
michel jeunesse chez acabit je suis
français j'appelle professionnels
[Musique]